hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 44 hört zu und
spricht nach
perfekt gleich hilfswerk haben oder sein
plus party zib 2
der unterricht beginnt um 9 uhr
beginnen beginnt er hat begonnen
beginnen er beginnt er hat begonnen
der unter
start um 9 uhr begonnen
ich bleibe zu hause
bleiben er bleibt er ist geblieben
ich bin zu hause geblieben
er bricht sich das bein
sich brechen erbricht sich er hat sich
gebrochen
er hat sich
das bein gebrochen
bahr
er bringt uns ein geschenk bringen sie
bringt sie hat gebracht
bringen sie bringt sie hat gebracht
sie hat uns ein geschenk gebracht
peter denk dann seine eltern denken er
denkt der hat gedacht
denken er denkt der hat gedacht
er hat
gedacht
manuela ist einen apfel essen
sie ist sie hat gegessen
essen sie ist sie hat gegessen
sie hat einen
viel gegessen
thomas
das gern velo fahren er fährt er ist
gefahren
fahren er fährt er ist gefahren
er ist oft velo gefahren
rahel findet einen fehler
finden sie findet sie hat gefunden
sie hat ein
gefunden maria fliegt in die ferien
fliegen sie fliegt sie ist geflogen
sie ist den die ferien geflogen
die flüchtlinge fliehen vor dem krieg
fliehen er flieht er ist geflohen
die flüchtlinge sind vor dem krieg
geflohen
meine mutter gibt mehr taschengeld
gebe
sie gibt sie hat gegeben
geben sie gibt sie hat gegeben
sie hat mir
geld gegeben
er geht in ein restaurant gehen er geht
er ist gegangen
gehen ihr geht er ist gegangen
er ist in ein restaurant gegangen
ruth gewinnt einen preis
gewinnen
sie gewinnt sie hat gewonnen
sie hat einen
preis gewonnen
paul hilft mir bei den hausaufgaben
helfen er hilft er hat geholfen
er hat mir bei den hausaufgaben geholfen
kathrin kennt viele leute
kennen sie kennt sie hat gekannt
sie hat viele leute gekannt
wenn leid uns sein velo leyen ihr leid
er hat geliehen
laien ihr leid er hat geliehen
er hat uns sein velo geliehen
elisabeth liest ein buch
lesen sie liest sie hat gelesen
sie hat ein buch gelesen
der kugelschreiber liegt auf dem tisch
liegen er liegt er ist hat gelegen
der kugelschreiber ist hat auf dem tisch
gelegen
tina lügt nie
[Musik]
lügen sie lügt sie hat gelogen
sie hat noch nie gelogen
simon marx sport mögen er mag er hat
gemacht
mögen er mag er hat gemacht
er hat
sport gemacht meine freuen
nimmt ein medikament
nehmen sie nimmt sie hut genommen
sie nimmt sie hut genommen
sie hat
ein medikament genommen